[Music]
it's been a crazy week in America let's
find out what happened
guys the midterm elections were Tuesday
and over 200 election deniers won but
sadly they didn't believe it
[Applause]
[Music]
well I won
no no no way I'm not I refuse to be the
murder this in town I am a loser I come
from a long line of losers my daddy was
a loser
Beaufort tea loser was his name
elected Republican Ron DeSantis as their
governor this week here's his acceptance
speech
[Music]
actual footage former White press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
elected as governor of Arkansas on
Tuesday making her the state's first
female governor she broke through the
glass ceiling and then called the cops
and blamed it on a black person
he elected me Governor I don't do a damn
loser
in other news comedian Sinbad turned 66
years old this week Amber Ruffin has
told lie after lie can you trust a
single word she says I certainly don't
think so hey
what are you doing an attack ad those
are over please it's all I know don't
get out of here sorry everybody this
thank you
this happens after every election
don't you glad for her she was being bad
you're reinforcing your bad behavior
look they release all those attack at
actors into the wild and they have a
hard time adjusting to regular life
anyway
as I was saying comedians Sinbad turned
66 years old Sinbad now that's a name I
can trust
you should trust him too
because America would be better with
Sinbad at the wheel
Sinbad steering America in the right
direction you have got to get out of
here
office are you Amber Ruffin has my vote
it's all
worse I'm sorry sorry everyone again
you're clapping only reinforces this bad
behavior I'm sorry you guys and Tarik
I'm also sorry sorry about that it is
okay sounds like it was personal or
anything Americans are sick of a lot of
things
inflation unemployment and tarek Davis
why is he always behind a Podium what's
he hiding why won't he show us his legs
vote Yes on Prop 18. four Sidekicks to
show you their legs
I want to see that today
look I'm sorry attack at season is done
but now that it's over you're gonna have
to find some other line of work you
can't just wander around here lost and
unfulfilled wait a second this is idea
are you feeling lost and unfulfilled
then try Zoloft
out of here
we need a security system to lock the
door I don't lock the door on principle
Amber this is a bad neighborhood
sneak into this show and then constantly
just fully miked yeah
they look beautiful and if something
goes down I don't have legs I can't run
[Applause]
sorry about that everybody let's get
back to the monologue
during the Houston Astros World Series
Victory Parade on Monday Senator Ted
Cruz was reportedly hit with a beer can
in the chest and neck it missed his
spine because he doesn't have one
[Applause]
all right
five Bakers in Mexico recently set a
Guinness World Record for the world's
largest bread Mosaic made of 20
689 loaves of bread they originally only
had Five Loaves but then this guy showed
up
who wants to get this party started it's
me white Jesus
that's why he only brings bread It Feels
Like Jesus that [ __ ] would have some
flavor yeah
[Applause]
who wants some cornbreads
like Jesus
[Music]
the second coming will be lit
according to reports a three-year-old
Shetland pony that is 20 inches tall may
be declared the world's smallest horse
while smallest ass is a tie between all
white women
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the rest is are pretty small
who wants some cornbreads
not me I have to watch my flat out
and
[Music]
and finally hug a bear day was this week
there were no survivors
well if you like that then hold on to
your butts because here comes another
fun thing
that's a lot about the news so far
tonight but you know what we haven't
talked enough about early 2000s r b
music well we're gonna change that right
now with tonight's surprise guest he's a
singer he's a dancer he's an icon and he
wrote The Single catchiest hook in the
history of music please welcome Cisco
[Applause]
what's up
welcome
Cisco hey hey
okay Cisco you're an amazing singer a
Flawless dancer and a Caesar cut
innovator your music is infectious and I
have literally never taken a road trip
without screaming one of your many hits
out the window thank you so much for
being here thank you for all of those
beautiful accolades thank you so much
okay now the lyrics
chose Mega
Mega hit songs are memorable it's
impossible to get them wrong but the
Amber Ruffin show asks what if you did
what would that sound like well let's
find out right now in America's newest
getting show the wrong song
[Music]
thank you
here's how it'll work Cisco and I will
take turns asking each other questions
and our answer will have to rhyme with
the famous line from The Thong Song
Cisco are you ready always
okay for round one all of our answers
will have to rhyme with the line dumps
like a truck truck truck here we go
and Cisco oh the little black thing in
hockey is called
uh a a puck Puck puck
yes I live in Minnesota now so you know
oh yeah oh okay that was easy
would you like to ask me a question sure
all right uh a person of color curses at
their mom they better what they better
duck duck duck
that's right
okay nailed it folks it's tied
do women do to their eyebrows
what do women do to their eyebrows when
what happens when they get unruly oh
okay uh
I don't know
we pluck pluck oh oh painful painful it
does it does hurt right right hey you
know Beauty pain sometimes eyebrows just
go well thank you thank you
yeah
hit me all right a Yiddish word that
means you're a jerk
you're you're you're you're you're
you're a schmuck schmuck nailed it
all right now that is the end of round
one all right I have two scores I have
two points it's one score guys this is
how scores work I only have one score
the one score is two points okay and
Cisco has one point one Cisco the
competition is intense are you buckling
underneath all this pressure
yeah yeah
[Applause]
I had to sneak that in there
bring it don't you call that [ __ ] A
Sneak I wanna hear it all the time round
two for this round all of our answers
we'll have to rhyme with the line fast
like what what what do you got it yeah I
got it okay let's go
Siskey can I call you Siskey only you
only you Amber
Cisco this Star Wars character loves
pizza Pizza Hut huh I'll take it I'll
take it it's driving us baby his friends
call him Pizza like I call Cisco sister
all right
um if RuPaul says
uh Shantae you stay
what should you do you bet you reviewed
you better stretch stretch stretch yeah
that's it that's what you do
[Applause]
Cisco I have a question for you it's
quite important okay if your throat
closes after you eat a PB and J you
might be allergic to a
[Laughter]
nuts nuts nuts
[Applause]
now when older black people eat ice
cream
it gives them a bloated
gives them a bloated butt butt
we were looking for gut but of course we
prefer butt right guys
[Applause]
what I wouldn't give or uploaded but
okay that is the end of round two now
the score is Amber Mildred Griffin with
three points
and Cisco Siskey Cisco with three points
inside all right okay yeah that's that's
my government name by the way
just just the most unoriginal mom of all
yep that was it three of the same name
she was just describing the pain oh
okay Cisco everything could change in
our last and most challenging round in
round three every answer must rhyme with
the memorable the catchy the iconic line
are you ready all right yeah let's do it
okay Cisco buddy is 4 20. I want to see
your
oh
bong
laughs
that is correct
all right uh they should have left this
big dude in the jungle he he climbed it
there we go
[Applause]
they bothered that monkey he was having
a nice time yeah all right with another
an unfortunate name for a delicious
snack cake
[ __ ] a ding ding dong
yeah now table tennis is just a fancy
name for
oh ping pong pong pong pong
[Applause]
okay Cisco our last and final question
is this what is the world's most
uncomfortable type of underwear
say with me that
[Applause]
hey let's
and gentlemen the final score is five
points and Cisco siski Cisco with six
boys
it was plus Cisco gets an extra 100
points for putting up with this nonsense
which means Cisco
yes
[Applause]
so bad for joining us today and thank
you for watching the wrong song
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign